[musique]
t mes copains quand je les vois
passer tous mes copains sont à
new tous mes copains Je les ai
embrasser tous mes copains m'aime bien
[musique]
tous mes copains il faut bien les aimer
tous mes copains savent
bien tous mes copains ont le jour et la
nuit tous mes copains m'aiment
bien l'armée me les emmène
par les quatres
chemins la nuit me les ramène
sans attendre
demain certains ne seront plus
certains sont
les revenus ils vont se
marier et Je ne les vois Plus
ous mes copains
s'en vont main dans la
main tous mes copains s'en
iront tous mes copains reprennent ront le
chemin tous mes copains sont
[musique]
parti
tous mes copains reprennent ront le
chemin tous mes copains sont
[musique]
parti
[Taper]
B